welcome everyone
this is Rob Sanders from simply learning
today we're gonna talk about SEO
tutorial for beginners so let's get
right to it and in this recording we're
gonna talk about a lot of topics related
to SEO so what's in it for you we're
gonna start with YF Co what is SEO we're
gonna talk about keyword research how
does a search engine work then we're
going to go into on-page and off-page
SEO and techniques and tactics related
to both of those we're gonna dive into
how Google algorithms work the types of
SEO website architecture local SEO how
to measure your SEO performance ie
analytics and then we gonna have a
little quiz at the end so a lot of
information in today's tutorial so let's
get right to it and start with why SEO
and some of you with a website maybe
your bloggers maybe you just have a
website with a lot of content probably
have this conversation before where you
said hey look I got all this content but
I can't be found on Google search
engines and the first reaction somebody
might have is well why don't you
optimize your website for SEO and some
of you may know what SEO is some of you
may not know what SEO is and the natural
question would be what is my website
need SEO what is SEO well there are a
lot of inherent benefits to SEO which
stands for search engine optimization
and the first benefit is it increases
visibility on search engines so all the
techniques we're going to cover today in
today's SEO tutorial are going to be
techniques to boost your visibility on
the search engines so we're not talking
about Google per se we're also talking
about Bing and Yahoo and Baidu and some
of the other search engines that are out
there so that's inherently the first
benefit to doing search engine
optimization is we want to increase our
visit
ability on search engines and today's
tutorial is going to cover that the
second benefit is it will rank help you
rank higher for relevant keywords so the
idea behind search engines is we want
our websites to be found our pages on
our websites to be found when somebody
does a search and so ideally when
somebody does a search you want to be
found for the keyword queries that are
most relevant to your business so we
want those keyword queries to match the
content that we have on our website and
so that's a benefit we want to be found
for what people are looking for and so
that's the beauty of SEO is that your
content could be found for those
relevant keywords the third benefit is
it helps to increase traffic to your
website so the idea here is a lot of
people go to search engines on a daily
basis around the world depending on what
search engine they use Google is one of
the most popular but if you look at
China Baidu is a popular search engine
nonetheless what's common around the
world is people do use search engines to
find information and so what we want to
do is we want to be found in search
engines because that's what people use
to find content and so we're found on
search engines people are going to find
us for relevant keywords and if they see
our content is relevant and the search
engine results after they query a
keyword then they're going to click on
our link and go to our website so if you
can imagine all that content you have on
your website and all that content is
able to be found on the search engines
and a lot of people are using search
engines with relevant keywords then
naturally you're gonna get clicks that's
going to drive traffic to your website
and so that's in summary how it works
and that's what we want we want to
increase traffic to our website from
search engines because that's what
people use and then inherently because
of that it will help people find our
website so an optimized site helps your
target audience find your website
increase brand awareness
so that's the idea if we could drive
traffic to our website from search
engines and multiple traffic sometime
from the same users it's going to
naturally also increase our brand
awareness people are going to know more
about us if we're found in the search
engines and then another benefit here is
it helps to convert a local business
into a global business what we mean by
that is if we're found in the search
engine results if somebody types on a
relevant keyword and our content shows
up in the search engine results on
google or Baidu or Bing or any search
engine ideally our business can be found
all over the world our content can be
found all over the world it's not
necessarily local per se we may have a
local business in a particular city or
locale but that doesn't stop anybody
from around the world from finding our
content so the idea behind search
engines is look the contents available
to anyone around the world and to me
this is one of the biggest benefits
because it can boost traffic it can
boost brand awareness it can boost
traffic and the whole idea is taking
your business and taking it and
elevating it to more of a global brand
versus just a local print and so that
inherently is one of the key benefits to
search engine optimization so let's move
on to what is SEO and we're going to
talk about SEO and how do you define it
so SEO again stands for search engine
optimization it's basically the practice
of getting traffic from the organic
search results on not just Google but
really any search engine so depending on
the keyword that somebody types in
regardless of what search engine they
use that search engines going to rank
websites based on the relevancy of the
keyword so if you have a website and you
have a blog and you have a lot of
content in your food blogger and you
write about let's just say restaurants
and you're doing restaurant reviews and
you happen to be doing a restaurant
review about Italian restaurants
well somebody typed in Italian
restaurants you may want to come up for
that keyword okay so it's all about
relevancy
does that search engines see that
particular blog post as the most
relevant for that search query so that's
what SEO is all about we want to be able
to rank our websites for certain
keywords on search engines so if our
website is ranked on search engines then
there's a lot of benefits to that we
talked about those benefits in the why
SEO but the biggest benefit is the
visibility that comes with that so the
higher your ranked on a search engine
the more traffic you're going to get and
it's a snowball effect because the more
traffic you get the more conversions
you're gonna get so here you can see the
percentage of Google traffic the higher
you rank so generally there are 10
results per page on a search engine so
if you're ranked in the top three or
even in the first or second position
you're gonna get a majority of the
clicks and search engine optimization
starts with the keyword because we want
to be found for relevant keywords and so
the first step and search engine
optimization is always going to be
keyword research so it is the most
important step and so what does keyword
research all about well it's process of
identifying keywords we want to be found
for on the search engines so millions of
people use search engines on a daily
basis we want to be found for those
keywords that people type in that are
relevant to the content we want to be
found so going back to the Italian
restaurant example if we're writing a
blog post about Italian restaurants if
somebody types in the best Italian
restaurants or Italian restaurants in a
specific city we want to be found for
that content if it's relevant to what we
wrote about so keyword research should
be done based on two factors really it's
based on the factor of how much traffic
or volume a particular search engine
query has and it's based on competition
and really the underlying factor here is
that all keywords in your keyword
research should be relevant so you need
to understand what those keywords are so
are they relevant to the content that
you want to be found for if they are
then really the two
you want to look for is the volume how
much volume or traffic each keyword has
associated with it and then the
competition how many other websites are
trying to be found for the same keyword
so those are the factors involved with
keyword research you always want to
choose relevant keywords and then once
you find or choose those relevant
keywords you want to be able to find out
exactly how much volume and how much
competition is associated with each of
those keywords and so when you look at
keywords you're always going to choose
relevant keywords but there are two
types of keywords there are short tail
keywords and there are long tail
keywords and we're going to talk about
both of these here so let's start with
short tail keywords so short tail
keywords are generic keywords generally
they're less than three words in a
keyword phrase for example Italian
restaurants so short tail keywords
generally have very high search volume
that means that if somebody types in
Italian restaurants then there's going
to be a large amount of volume with that
meaning that generally a lot of people
type in the keyword Italian restaurants
however with high volume always comes
high competition so if you want to be
found for Italian restaurants know that
you are ranked number one or number two
or even on page one of Google you're
going to get a lot of traffic however to
get to page one of Google or even
position one or two it's going to take
you a while because they're probably a
lot of websites who are in front of you
who want to be ranked and found for the
same keyword so the whole idea with
short tail keywords is it's a lot of
visibility it's a lot of traffic a lot
of volume but also a lot of competition
and generally the underlying factor here
is that if you are ranked for a very
broad or short tail keyword like Italian
restaurants then chances are it's not
going to be as relevant so if you get
the traffic to your website then chances
are the conversions not necess
really gonna happen because we don't
necessarily know the mindset of somebody
typing in a very short tail generic
keyword like a tie in restaurants they
could be doing research on Italian
restaurants they could be a chef who's
trying to get recipes for Italian food
it could be worse looking for Italian
restaurants in a different City
or it could be a person just looking for
Italian restaurants near their location
or where they're living and so there's a
lot of different factors with short tail
keywords so you just don't know because
it's so generic and because it's so
generic if you do get the traffic for
that generic keyword then the chances of
the conversion are going to be lower
than say if it's a more specific
relevant keyword so let's take an
example of a short tail keyword let's
just stick with Italian restaurants so
I'm gonna go to a tool called Moz and
while Moz has a tool called the keyword
explorer and within Moz so if you go to
Moz comm and then use the keyword
explorer
you can get an idea of how much volume
and competition are associated with a
particular keyword so in this example
we're using Italian restaurants it's a
very broad keyword we could see that the
monthly volume is between 70,000 and 118
thousand per month okay so that means
for a particular keyword in the United
States on a search engine you're going
to get about seventy thousand to one
hundred eighteen thousand people who
type in that keyword and so if we were
looking at the difficulty of that
keyword you can see that it's fairly
difficult because out of one to one
hundred it's going to score forty three
so it's fairly difficult however if you
notice to click the rates very high so
Moz estimates that we'll have a forty
percent organic click the rate for that
keyword if we're rank for it so if it's
relevant to us and we want to get some
visibility to our site then yeah we want
to use that generic short tail keyword
however if we're interested in
conversions then we really want to turn
our attention to longer tail keywords
however if you want the visibility then
you want to use short tail keywords if
you want the conversion then you want to
switch over to longer tail keyword so
longer tail
keywords are more specific they usually
consist of more than three keywords so
tie-in restaurants very generic if we
add a few more keywords that keyword
phrase it then becomes longer tail so
compared to short tail keywords longer
tail keywords are generally less
competitive and the search volume is not
as high
case in point so if we go back to Moz
and then we look at the keyword explorer
and we'd actually type in a tie in
restaurants and let's just say Orlando
Florida Moz is going to generate some
monthly volume for us and they're gonna
allow us to understand how difficult
that keyword is and so here you can see
very very little search volume in fact
so little volume there's eleven 250 ok
so that means on average that this
keyword generates 11 250 queries a month
so very low compared to our short tail
keyword Italian restaurants the
difficulty here didn't necessarily
lessen but it is less competitive so if
you're interested in conversions and you
have an Italian restaurant and say
Orlando Florida then this is the keyword
you may want to use so there's a
trade-off between longer tail and
shorter tail
well when visitors land from longer tail
keywords they're usually ready to make a
purchase they're usually more specific
intent there's more intent involved with
a longer tail keyword so best
restaurants in a time in Florida branded
shoes in Florida something very specific
is going to generate probably a higher
conversion rate than something more
generic so that's the trade-off
and so when to use long tail keywords
well we want to use long tail keywords
and for targeting pages with a product
or specific article so if we're
interested in that particular conversion
then longer tail keywords are likely
more the way we want to go versus
something more generic which means if
you're using a generic shorter tail
keyword you're more interested in the
visibility and the traffic not
necessarily the conversion how does a
search engine work so let's talk about
that for a minute so we know that means
people use search engine
we know that we want to be found on
search engines but how do we actually
get our content in the search engines so
that's the important part that we need
to understand if we have our own website
and we have our content so these search
engines want your content in their
search engine index so how do they get
your content well they send out BOTS or
files and we'll just call them spiders
so they send out these spiders to crawl
your website and the whole idea behind
using the insect spider is because we're
talking about the world wide web and so
if Google for example sends a bot to
your website they're gonna crawl your
website and spider your web so the
creating a web of pages so all they're
doing is following link and every page
and link that they hit they're going to
bring back to their server so these
spiders scan your web sites they just
follow links and they take all the pages
and content that they're able to gather
when they hit your website and they're
going to pull all that information back
into their own index so if you think
about Google they're crawling or
spidering millions and billions of web
sites all those millions and billions of
web sites are sitting on Google servers
so when somebody does do a search query
Google because they have all these
websites and their index are able to
quickly determine which website is the
most relevant for that search engine
queries so that's generally how search
engines work so let's talk about the
types of SEO so if we want our website
to be found on these search engines and
Google or these search engines have
crawled our website then what we want to
do is we want to basically look at it
from a two pronged perspective it's a
two prong strategy so the first strategy
we're gonna talk about today is on-page
SEO so those are on page SEO is defined
as what we do on our website to be
relevant for search engine query on a
search engine so again on page SEO is
what we do to our own website off page
SEO is the other the second part of that
SEO strategy and off page SEO determines
what we do
our website to be relevant for search
engine query and so off page SEO
generally is synonymous with link
building and we'll talk about that a
little bit more as we go forward but
really when you want to do SEO when you
want to be found for a keyword on a
search engine you're going to have to
apply but with on-page SEO and off page
SEO so let's talk about on-page SEO and
so this is the first part of our SEO
effort we want to focus on on page SEO
first and so on page SEO is the method
of optimizing elements of web pages
remember these are all the items we want
to do on our website to be relevant for
certain search queries so it's basically
the idea behind this is to make our web
pages more relevant for specific search
queries on search engines and so there
are a number of different elements on
our website on a particular web page
that we want to manipulate or optimize
if you will to be relevant for search
engine query and so let's start around
the idea that you know you there's a
number of things you can do so let's
start with schema first and so schema is
nothing more than it's a collaborative
effort between Bing Yahoo Baidu Google
and the idea is really they want to
understand more about the content of
your website and so the idea behind this
is that you want to be able to provide
snippets of information to these search
engines so they understand a little bit
more about what your web page is trying
to portray or convey so that they can
find out exactly what's relevant to that
search engine query so it's nothing more
than micro data or bits of information
that you can add to your website or web
page in order to provide a little bit
more enhanced information to the search
engines so if you think about it's
collaborating with the search engine so
the more basic information you share
with the search engines that the better
off they have to under
and what your webpage or website is all
about and so the more information they
have the better of an opportunity you
have to be ranked for that search engine
query and so if you have a website with
reviews if you have a website with
images if you have let's say a website
with products with prices in other words
you have an e-commerce website and
you're trying to sell product well to me
you want to employ schema because in
schema is snippets of information that
are provided to the search engines so
they can better understand so you can
certainly provide snippets of
information in the terms of images or
prices or particular products and how
much is left in stocks so all this
information these bits of information
you can provide to the search engines so
that they can better understand what it
is you're trying to sell how much it
caused how much is in inventory what
people think about the product etc so if
you have a website that's sub products
you probably want to employ schema and
so when you do employ schema again
snippets of information provided to the
search engines the search engines are
going to better understand and then
they're going to present that
information in the search engine results
so if you have ratings and reviews you
can provide snippets of information to
the search engines the search engines in
turn are going to present that
information in the search engine results
so if you have positive reviews then
somebody typing in in this example shoes
they're going to be able to see that you
have positive reviews for your websites
so that's the whole idea behind schema
is to provide snippets of information so
again it's not just related to reviews
also for images so if you have images
you can provide snippets of information
to the search engine so they can see you
know what the shoe actually looks like
when they type in in this example Puma
shoes or like I mentioned inventory
snippets of information about your
inventory the search engines are going
to provide that information search
engine results so if somebody's looking
for women's training shoes or women's
Puma shoes and they see your product and
they see how this is in stock great let
me go to this website
and purchase these shoes so that's the
whole idea behind schema is making sure
you present information critical to your
website so that the search engines
better understand what your website's
all about it also house with relevancy
because the more those search engines
know about your website the more
relevant your website becomes and the
better chance you have to rank for a
particular keyword there's also some
other information here involved with
schema and those are site links so site
links additional pages on your website
ok that's show up in the search engine
result and so again the more information
a search engine has about you the better
chance you have to be found the better
chance you have to get it clicked so
site links are just additional links on
your site that appear in search engine
results and that's all a benefactor of
having schema so here you can see in
this example we have additional web
pages that show under certain search
engine results and so by having more
links in the search engine results you
have a better chance of getting the
click so if you want more information
about schema I would recommend going to
schema.org so when you go to schema.org
you can actually click on a link that
allows you to see all the information
you need to get started with schema.org
okay so it's got a lot of information
available to you it describes what it is
you have to do in order to get your
information and set for these search
engines to better understand Ghassan for
on page SEO is title tag and so title
tag is which shows up and the search
engine results so if you've ever done a
search engine query meaning you've gone
to Google typed in a query using a
keyword like Italian restaurants you're
gonna see specific search engine results
and the title tag is what appears in
those search engine results so a title
tag is important because it's the title
of a web page that appears in those
results and so the title tag is
something that's important because if we
want to be found for specific keyword we
want to make sure that keyword is in the
title tag because that keywords gonna
describe what the page is all about
and so if we want to be found for that
keyword let's just say Italian
restaurants in Florida for example
that's going to be part of our title tag
so when somebody types in that
particular keyword query Italian
restaurants in Florida then we have a
good chance of showing up because the
title tag which is the title of the page
is going to have that particular query
in it and so you can edit the title tag
and when you edit the title tag you want
to be able to put that particular
keyword in the title tag so if we do a
search on Google for example so if I go
to google.com and I type in Italian
restaurants and Florida
here I can see under the local search
results and here I can see Italian
restaurants in Florida Central Florida
ten restaurants in Miami so you can see
that these are highlighted so the title
tag is not only stands out but allows
you to you know showcase exactly what
your page is all about and it helps with
the relevancy of that keyword query so
when you're trying to optimize your
website using the title tag for specific
keyword you want to keep it in mind a
couple parameters because title tags
show up in the search engine results but
certain search engines particularly
Google has character limits around the
number of characters you can use in the
title tag and so we want to keep that in
mind so ideally we want to format our
title tag appropriately and so to me the
most optimal way to optimize a title tag
using a particular keyword that you want
to be found for is to use that keyword
in the title tag and then separate that
with your brand name so if you actually
have two keywords then you can use the
primary keyword first then the secondary
keyword and then the brand name so to me
this is the most optimal format but keep
in mind there are character limits but
if you look at this format to me it's
the most easiest format to abide by
because it makes your title tag more
relevant you don't have to worry about
necessarily fitting in excess keywords
in the title tag because again the title
tag is character limits so if we take a
look at our example in Google search
results if you go over those limits and
the title tag is generally between 60
and 65 characters long and so if you go
over those limits let's just say your
title tag is more than 65 characters
Google in this case is going to cut off
big characters and so here you can see
the ellipses after the title tag now if
you follow the format that you know we
at simply learned recommend you can see
if our keyword is Italian restaurants in
Florida and then separated by the brand
name this gives you an optimal format
for
title tag it also makes it relevant for
the keyword query so you want to keep
that title tag probably no more than 60
characters because you'd flirt with
putting more than 60 characters then the
search engines are going to cut off that
title tag and then that's not going to
look good and it's gonna also become
less relevant so we want to keep the
character counts in mind so if you abide
by that format of the keyword and then
maybe the secondary keyword if you have
one separated by the brand name then you
should be good to go with making sure
your title tag is relevant for that
keyword query so let's then turn our
attention to the Meta Description so the
Meta Description is just a short
description about the content on your
web page so if the title tag is the
title of the webpage the Meta
Description describes the page okay so
it's a description about what that page
is so the meta description appears under
the title tag and then the URL so if we
go back to our Google search results we
look here Italian restaurants in Florida
Maggiano's Little Italy is the brand or
the restaurant we could see the URL
which is underneath the title tag and
then here we could see the Meta
Description and so with the Meta
Description you have a little bit more
room to work with in terms of character
counts but the Meta Description just
like the table tag is just as important
because one it shows up in the search
engine results two it describes what the
page is all about and three it allows
you to optimize the Meta Description so
the Meta Description becomes more
relevant for that search query that
somebody types in to that particular
search engine so the optimal length for
a Meta Description you can go up to 300
characters but I would not even
recommend even flirting with that limit
because just like the title tag search
engines in the case of Google will
actually cut off the Meta Description so
if we look here back at our search
results if you go over those limits
you'll see that the search engines will
cut off the copy of the Meta Description
width and they'll just put ellipses so
we don't
necessarily want to go over those limits
so my recommendation is to keep that
Meta Description probably a hundred and
sixty-five characters two to no more
than 200 because we're trying to
describe not only what the page is all
about but we're also trying to optimize
that Meta Description so it becomes
relevant for the search engine query and
so you want to keep it short and concise
so if we look at our example here
Italian restaurants in Florida
Maggiano's is a good job it's a book an
event space make a reservation at
Maggiano's in florida to enjoy delicious
few maps menus and more so very concise
Meta Description it includes their
keyword query that they want to be found
for Italian restaurants in Florida and
so to me it's short and concise
describes what the page is all about and
allows them to fit it all in within the
character limits so here in this example
we want to be found for Amazon Puma
shoes so the brand here is Amazon so
Amazon wants to include you know Puma
shoes not only in the title tag but they
want to try and fit that into the Meta
Description
however the whole idea behind the Meta
Description more than anything else is
describe what the page is all about okay
you want to be relevant for the search
engine query but you also want to sound
natural as well you want to be able to
really the whole idea between the tail
tagging amount of description is to get
people to click on your link because
remember there are nine other listings
on the Google search engine results page
for page one so we want our Meta
Description and our title tag to stand
out so we want it to be relevant who we
want it to stand out so it's important
you write that Meta Description
according to what the page is all about
but you want it to stand out uniquely
and accordingly so once you've done the
title tag and the Meta Description you
want to focus your attention on a header
tag and so header tags are used on a web
page to really separate out content and
so you have headers and sub headers and
so ideally you want to be able to
optimize the header tag and
sub-header and so if we think about a
headers there's a hierarchy for headers
so there's between a header one and a
header six and so we'll just shorten the
word header and we'll call it an h1 so
h1 is really at the top of the hierarchy
for headers and so if we use that h1 on
our webpage then what we're trying to
explain that the search engines is
listen this particular keyword phrase in
our header is is a header and we're
emphasized what it is we're trying to
say and that's how really the search
engines interpret headers they see an h1
h2 h3 h4 h5 and h6 they know that if
you're using an h1 you're trying to
really emphasize something so if you put
that keyword in the header tag what
you're telling the search engines is hey
I'm really emphasizing this particular
keyword and so the search engine will
interpret that as important and if you
use your keyword in that header then
really what you're saying is hey I
really this keyword is really relevant
to that query
so naturally the other benefit of a
header is it really breaks up the page
as well so the header you can use sub
headers and sub patters are nothing more
than say a lower H tag so if you have a
header that's an h1 you can use an h2
and h3 as a sub header and so forth and
so on because what you're really trying
to do is not only organize the content
in your webpage but you're trying to
emphasize that for google so if
something's an h2 or an h6
you're basically telling Google or the
other search engines this is not as
important to say an h1 so if we take a
look at our example that we've been
using for tallien restaurants in Florida
and if we click on Maggiano's we could
see that they're using headers so if we
click on Maggiano's we can see that this
is a header here we want to bring
everyone together Maggiano's Italian
restaurant in Florida so they're using
that header to break up the text here
you can see they're using another header
here
excellent Italian food and an excellent
experience to match so that's a header
to break up the content ok they're not
using sub headers
they're using headers but that's fine
they're really trying to emphasize the
content by putting in that header and so
headers help not only organize the
content but they help emphasize the
actual keyword it is you want Google to
recognize so if we're not sure if
something is a header we could simply
just mouse over what we think is a
header and we can just right click and
if you right click on something you're
gonna see a menu and if we click inspect
element then basically what that browser
in this case Firefox is going to do is
show us the HTML of that particular
thing of that item that we right-click
so here we could see in this particular
case this is an h2 tag
so it's an h2 so if we scroll down and
we mouse over this we could see this is
also an h2 as well so this particular
page is using h2 tags not h1 but an h2
so what they're explaining or trying to
convey to the search engines is listen
this is an h2 it's still relevant we're
still trying to put emphasis on it but
not as much so we want to be able to use
our H ones and our h2s accordingly so
remember an h1 is you're providing the
search engines with information by
telling them hey this is the most
relevant this is we're putting emphasis
on this keyword and h2 nuts as much as
an h1 and h3 not as much as an h2 so use
your headers accordingly not only just
to break up the text not only for
styling but for emphasis for the search
engines so headers are very important
elements for on-page SEO let's turn our
attention to the URL structure
okay so URL stands for Uniform Resource
locator and so our URL is the specific
location of a webpage on the Internet so
basically if we're found in the search
engine results one of our web pages are
gonna go along with the title tag in the
Meta Description in the search engine
results page so if I go back to our
search engine results for Italian
restaurants in Florida we could see that
the particular URL in question here is
occations Maggiano's dot-com / florida
so that's the URL that shows up along
with the title tag in the Meta
Description so if we click on that link
that's exactly where we're gonna go
so URL structure is important for
on-page SEO so why is it important
because not only does it show people
where they're going but we have an
opportunity to optimize that URL for the
search engines to make our URL more
relevant for that search query so just
like the title tag just like the Meta
Description just like the headers we can
also manipulate the URL so if we look at
a URL it consists of really the protocol
and the protocol means it's either a
secure site or non secure site so in
this example we can see it's HTTPS and
that means it's a secure site and so
ideally search engines like web pages or
web sites that are secure so after the
protocol you're gonna see the domain and
then after the domain you're gonna see
subdirectories okay so that's generally
the breakout with a URL structure so you
have the protocol the domain and
subdirectories and then you may have
more subdirectories so if we go back to
the example we've been working with if I
go back to you Maggiano's you can see
here this is a secure site HTTPS you can
see the domain in this case it's
actually a sub domain so Maggiano's com
is the domain but they decided to put
locations dot Maggiano's com and that's
okay we call that a subdomain and then
here you can see they have one
particular
subdirectory after the domain and that's
Florida so a well-structured URL not
only provides the users with information
about where they're going when they
click on your link in the search engine
results but more importantly it also
provides the search engines and some
information about what the page is all
about so going back to our simple
example with Maggiano's the search
engines know that hey if somebody clicks
on this link they're going to a page
about Florida pretty
simple the URL structure is pretty
simple to understand we know it's a
secure site we know its Maggiano's calm
and we know the sub page is Florida with
subdirectories Florida you want to be
careful like everything else since in
SEO there are parameters just like the
title tag has parameters up to 65
characters the Meta Description tag has
a limit of up to 165 characters a well
structured URL also has character counts
but the idea here is we don't want to
get into numbers when we talk about
character counts for URL structure
really the rule of thumb or the best
practice for you URL is to keep it short
and understandable okay if we keep it
clear and concise not only does the end
user know where they're going but the
search engines know what the page is all
about so the rule of thumb is always if
you don't understand the URL or what it
means then the search engines are likely
not going to understand what the URL
means we want to keep the number of
directors and subdirectories to a limit
so ideally here you can see in this
example xyz.com if we want to optimize
that URL we could put the targeted
keyword in the URL if we'd like to but
we want to keep it probably to a minimum
of one to two subdirectories the shorter
this the amount of subdirectories the
better off we are because that means
that not only the end user will
understand the URL but the search
engines will understand the URL as well
so we always want to make sure that URL
is readable again for the end user and
the search engine and so in this example
you can see amazon.com slash men's -
shoes slash sneakers slash Puma very
easy understand as an end user I know
that I'm going to a puma page for men on
amazon.com now when you get into your
rels with dynamic parameters in them
then ideally you as an end user is not
going to really know where you're going
to go so in the example here the middle
example I can see that I'm going maybe
to a shoes page but I have no idea
with the rest that URL means and in the
other example where you have a very low
URL readability I have no idea as an
end-user where I'm going to go so as an
end user I need to be able to have
confidence in knowing where I'm gonna go
once I click on a link in the search
engine results so if I don't have that
confidence if I don't understand what
the URL is then the you then the search
engines aren't going to understand as
well and it's not going to bode well in
terms of relevancy and again the URL
structure is important factor for being
relevant and if we're not relevant then
the chances of us are ranking higher is
not going to be as good because our URL
is not readable so ideally what we want
to do is make sure we're using keywords
that the end-user in the search engines
understand and if we need to separate
out those keywords in the first example
we could see men's shoes we want to
separate that out with a hyphen and so
ideally if you have a URL that's
readable and it's short and concise then
again your chances of ranking higher on
the search engine results page bodes
better than if you have a very long
antiquated unreadable URL so let's focus
our attention on image alt text or alt
tags if you will so alt tags or text
tags as they're also known as allow the
search engines to understand a little
bit more about what's on the page in
terms of images so images are a
prominent part of every webpage on the
Internet
unfortunately images are you know
usually files that are not readable by
search engines so we want to be able to
provide some alternate text so that the
search engines understand what those
images are all about so again it gives
us an opportunity to communicate with
the search engines so that they better
understand what the image is all about
to make the page more relevant so
generally if an image fails to load on a
web page as an example well if you have
an alt tag then the alt tag is going to
show in place of the image not loading
more importantly if we
have an alt tag and the search engines
have spidered our website and somebody's
actually searching for images then the
alt tag is used as a descriptor for the
image so it Hustle helps us get found
for the images on search engine results
pages and so like everything else we've
talked about with on-page SEO there are
character limits to alt tags you know
generally the rule of thumb is 125
characters for an alt tag and the alt
tag is used in the HTML so we want to
surround our image with an alt tag by
putting in a descriptor and so ideally
if you're trying to be found for a
particular search engine query then you
want to use the search engine query as
part of the alt tag and so let me show
you an example here
going back to Maggiano's we look at
their web page and we actually inspect
one of their images on this web page if
we look at for example a Pinterest or
Facebook we can actually see in this
example that the image here has an alt
tag as Pinterest and so you want to be
able again to put in alt tags for all
your images so it better communicates
with the search engines what the image
is all about it also allows the search
engines to rank images in the search
engine results based on that alt text
and what the keyword query was so alt
tags play an important role because
again if the image doesn't load on the
webpage for some reason then the alt tag
is there as a replacement it's also
there to help the search engines rank
those images and understand the page a
little bit better so you always want to
be able to put in the keyword query that
you're trying to be found for in the alt
tag and so be as descriptive as possible
you have a hundred and twenty-five
characters to use so be as descriptive
make it easy to read because again this
is what's going to show up in the search
engine results
just for images okay let's turn our
attention to internal links so when it
comes to SEO internal links also play a
vital role because basically an internal
link which is a link from one page of
your website to another page of your
website allows Google to or other search
engines really to follow the pages as
they index your entire website so it
serves that purpose of allowing search
engines to index so it definitely
improves the indexing but internal
linking also has many benefits and one
of the other benefits is it helps
spreads what we call link juice and so
link juice is basically a way another
way of saying you know this page is
important because it has links from
other pages on our website so if we link
I have a link from one page to another
and a couple of other pages on our site
linked to that same page then search
engines tend to take notice and they
tend to note that you know if one
particular page has a number of
different links pointing to it then this
page may be important and so that's what
we mean by link juice it's a signal for
the search engines to determine what
pages on your website are important
because of the links that point to it
and so if we look at this example here
we could see that you know there's
usually a navigation on a website that
point to pages and every page on a
website tends to have a link but if more
than one page has multiple links then
again that signals to the search engines
that hey you know this particular page
seems to be important because it has a
lot of Link's pointing to it our
attention to site maps so sitemaps
basically allow us to list all the web
pages on our website so we could do that
in a couple of different ways but when
we do it it basically is going to and
help the search engines find our page is
easier just as I mentioned a minute ago
about internal linking when you have one
link point to another page on your
website it helps the search engines find
these pages quicker
well sitemaps do
same thing except sitemaps are an entire
list of links on your website and it
allows the site search engines to find
all your pages and you would say fairly
easily but it also helps the end user to
so if you have a big website like Amazon
has a huge website with a lot of
different products well if you're
looking for a particular product you can
do a search for it or you can look at
the site map and the site map will list
all the particular pages on the site and
so it's also good for the end user as
well so when we talk about the end user
and we talk about search engines there
are really two different types of
sitemaps you got the HTML version which
is for the end user that's gonna be
nothing more than a link on the website
usually in the footer and so when you
click on that sitemap link you'll get a
list of all the links on the website ok
so that's an HTML sitemap then we have
the sitemap for the search engines
you know the spiders that want to crawl
our site so that's the XML sitemap and
in XML is just a different format it's
just a way to format all the links on
our website so the HTML sitemap is HTML
written in hypertext markup language
designed for the end user if you click
on it it helps the end user navigate the
website quickly because they can find
what they're looking for and so
generally that is an HTML now if we turn
our attention to the XML sitemap that's
basically designed for search engines
and thing about the search the XML
sitemap is we work with Google to go
ahead and and and submit the sitemap to
Google so Google can quickly understand
what pages on our website so for example
if I went to a website let's just say
valley fig com so if I went here and if
I'm a search engine I'm gonna want to
know all the URLs that are on this
website well as an end user I can also
just type in sitemap dot XML usually
that's the XML file where all the URLs
are located and here I can see all of
the URLs on Valley fit com and so the
idea behind an XML sitemap is we want to
communicate that XML file to the search
engines and so Google in particular has
they call a search console in search
console if you go to google.com slash
webmasters so search console is a way to
communicate with Google and one of the
ways to communicate with Google is to
submit a sitemap so we want to submit
our XML sitemap so if our XML sitemap is
located in the root directory so after
our domain valley fig comm slash sitemap
XML we know that that file is sitting in
the root directory I can go into search
console and I can submit my site map and
when I submit my site map then I'm
basically communicating with Google
telling Google hey Google instead of
trying to find all our web pages on our
website when you crawl the website we're
going to go ahead and submit the sitemap
to you so we're gonna tell you all the
pages on our website and so by doing
that by submitting our sitemap XML file
to Google it speeds up the process
because Google's able to now understand
all the pages on our website that have
been submitted and then once we submit
those pages then Google is going to
quickly index a majority of those pages
if not all of those pages and so that's
the benefit of having an XML sitemap for
the search engines is that we can
quickly submit that file to the search
engine so our pages get submitted and
indexed quicker so continuing on with
on-page SEO we now turn our attention to
PageSpeed and so PageSpeed also known as
page low time of a particular page of a
particular website is important for SEO
why is it important because Google has
millions of users use their search
engine and Google wants their users to
have a good experience and so if Google
ranks websites based on relevancy they
also want to take into account PageSpeed
because if a website does not load fast
or a web page doesn't load fast then it
would be detrimental for Google to rank
that page high because what's going to
happen is that page is going to get a
number of clicks and then the user
experiences not
to be that great and so therefore it's
gonna have a negative impact not only in
the end-user but Google as well and so
page load time then becomes important
for on-page SEO so really when it comes
to page load time we really want to pay
attention to how long it takes our web
pages to load in terms of seconds
because if a page loads slow then
chances are the user experience is not
going to be good even from an analytics
perspective meaning if I go to Google
type in a query click on a link and then
it's that link takes me to a website
where the webpage loads very slow
chances are I'm not gonna spend a lot of
time waiting for that page to load I'm
going to leave that page and if I leave
the page then it's gonna cause up what
they call a bounce so I'm going to
bounce from the page and that's just not
good for the entire search ecosystem and
so we want to pay close attention to
page load time because the faster a site
or page loads Google's going to
recognize that and that's going to help
with ranking and so how do we understand
how our pages load well we can look no
further than web analytics tool like
Google Analytics for example so if we
turn our attention to Google Analytics
if I go to say valley fig comms
analytics account I can look over the
last 30 days and I can see ok on average
our page average page load time for the
entire site was 5 seconds around 5
seconds and ideally we want our pages
load as quick as possible I would say
the rule of thumb on page load time is
probably no more than 3 to 4 seconds ok
but there are factors involved with page
load time so a couple of factors are the
browser that people use
so some browsers load pages differently
than other browsers the other factor
involved with browsers is the device so
you could be on a mobile device and say
Internet Explorer versus on a desktop
using Chrome and you're going to have
variation in terms of average page load
time so definitely browser device plays
a role but also country plays a role the
infrastructure how much bandwidth is
available so you could be in say San
Francisco United States and be on a
high-speed network versus another city
or another country where you're not
necessarily on the same high-speed
network you're on a lower bandwidth or
lower network and that's going to affect
the page load time as well so in
analytics you can actually see the
breakdown of time per country and then
of course the page itself so when we
talk about an average page load time for
a website we're talking about the
average for the entire site but we can
actually look at in Google Analytics the
average load time for every page on the
site so ideally if you have a particular
page you want to rank organically in the
search engines and the average page load
time is not suitable or it's very high
then you want to address what the issues
are and so the great thing about Google
Analytics is you actually have speed
suggestions so if I go to speed
suggestions in Google Analytics I'm
going to be able to see the average load
time for certain pages on the site and
then what Google's going to do is
actually give me some feedback so for
example I can see that the home page
loads about five point five nine seconds
and so if I click on PageSpeed
suggestions then Google is going to give
me suggestions on how to speed up the
page load time not only on desktop but
on mobile as well so when you click on
its page speed suggestions you're
actually going to go to a tool a Google
tool called PageSpeed insights and then
PageSpeed insights is going to allow you
to see how quick your page loads and
then it's going to be able to give you
feedback on what to do in order to speed
up the page load time not only for the
page but for the site and the great
thing again is you can see it for
desktop and you can see it from mobile
so PageSpeed is important we want to be
able to keep our page load time low no
more than probably again three to four
seconds because if it's any more than
Google's going to take notice the other
search engines are going to take notice
and they're not going to want to rank
that particular page high on Google so
some ways to increase your page speed
you always want to optimize your images
you never want to have images that take
a long time to load you want to use the
simple website design now I know flash
as an example has long been disbanded
but you don't want to use other
technology that's really going to slow
the page load time of course where your
website is hosted does matter so the
server it's hosted on could be shared
with other web sites and so that may eat
into how quick the server responds to
people trying to load your web page and
so you want to keep that in mind so
server response time does play a factor
in loading and then of course optimizing
your code you want to never have
unnecessary code on your website and
when I say unnecessary code some
examples could be tracking code if
you're doing any search advertising
let's just say on Facebook or Bing you
try to want to minimize the amount of
extra code you put on a site because
that code has to execute and that eats
into the page load time so you want to
be cognizant of how much code you put on
your website because that will eat into
the page load time so let's talk about
featured snippets so featured snippets
is the search result that generally
shows up at the top of the search engine
organic results so it's informational
content and you'll see it above organic
results but you'll also see it below
search advertising and so some of the
common features that you may see are in
the form of a paragraph a table or a
list and so paragraph snippets tend to
be the most popular and let me show you
an example of a featured snippet so if I
go to say google.com and type in machine
learning here you can see some paid
search ads okay and why do I another
paid search ads because I can see ad
next to them but if I look below the
paid search ads but above the organic
search
I see a paragraph featured snippet and
this is nothing more than again just
some informational content about machine
learning and really the whole idea
behind featured snippets is really
they're just informational and really
it's informational and and what Google
likes to do is pull content in there
that really answers a question so if
your content doesn't necessarily answer
question then you can't expect your
content to show up as a featured snippet
so the whole idea is with the search
engines is really Google searches
through a number different sites to find
content that will best answer a user's
question like for example what is
machine learning okay so if we ask the
question what is machine learning we can
expect to find a feature snippet and so
really what users do a lot when they
type in a query they use prefixes like
how does or how do or how to or what is
and so those types of questions are
normally asked as part of the search
query so if you can answer those
questions then generally Google is going
to recognize that and if it's relevant
it's gonna show up as a featured snippet
so the whole idea is to really create
truly high quality content so about
feature snippets is if you have true
high quality content that answers a
question then chances are your content
may show up as a featured snippet so the
whole idea is you know work to create
high quality content that provides a
really good answer to really basic
question it could be anything what is
machine learning what is a fig you know
how to ride a bicycle how do I surf all
these are related questions that content
can answer and Google wants to make sure
as part of a feature snippet that they
provide content that answers that
question and not just content the best
content that does the the best job with
the most relevant information answer
that person sir
very so here we could see our three
examples you have a table format so if
we want to type in Aviation jobs we can
see snippets of information about the
latest job listings for aviation you can
see in the middle screenshot what is
machine learning so that's our paragraph
featured snippet and then if you type in
something like building a fence it's
gonna give you a list of you know ways
to go about building a fence so these
are all answers to questions the query
may not necessarily be in question form
but the snippet is there just in case
you want to know more information about
that particular query so generally
that's how featured snippets work and
the great thing about featured snippets
it's open to everybody the key is to
have quality content if you have quality
content that provides answers to
questions then chances are your content
can show up above organic search results
which will give you more visibility
drive a lot more traffic to your site
and quality traffic because likely it's
answering somebody's question so let's
do a a recap of everything we talked
about with on-page SEO so before we move
on off page remember on-page SEO is what
we do to our website to enhance our
website to be found in the search
engines for relevant keywords so it's
all about relevancy and remember before
you do anything to your website you need
to start with the basics of keyword
research you need to find keywords that
are highly relevant that have volume and
low competition and so when you can
focus on your keywords and you find out
and finalize what keywords you want to
be found for then you're going to
conduct on-page SEO on page SEO consists
of number of different factors some of
which we talked about today starting
with schema remember we want to have
structured data to better communicate
with the search engines what our web
pages are about then we talked about
title tags so title tags appear in
search results remember 65 characters we
want to make sure our keyword is
in the title tag followed by our brand
name and then we talked about meta
descriptions meta descriptions allow us
to you talk specifically about what that
page is all about meta descriptions fall
under the title tag in the search
results we talked about headers h1
through h6 h1 being the biggest and the
hierarchy of headers and having an h1
tag with your keyword provides the
search engines with an identity of how
strong or how important something is on
a page it also organizes the page with
headers and sub headers and it breaks up
the content so it's easily
understandable by the end user we also
talked about alt tags so remember images
on its own are not recognized by search
engines so we want to surround those
images with alt tags with words that
help the search engines identify what
that image is they also serve a purpose
in the browser if an image doesn't load
then we can actually see what the image
is all about with the alt tag we talked
about feature snippets there are lists
ok their paragraphs ok they're there
different types of snippets and really
the whole idea again behind snippets is
answering a question with quality
content we talked about Page Speed
identifying how quick our pages load in
Google Analytics so if your pages don't
load very quickly then Google actually
provides suggestions to speed up the
page load time of a particular page and
some of the culprits that you want to
look at are making sure you have images
that are good quality but also not a lot
in size you want to make sure they're
optimized you want to look at your
server response time you want to make
sure you optimize code so there's a lot
of different factors of page load time
you just want to keep an eye on what
pages are not loading quick enough and
remember we want to keep it as low as
possible but no more than 3 to 4 seconds
we talked about internal linking
internal linking to a particular page
from one page to another provides link
juice and link juice is nothing more
than an indicator for the search engines
to identify what pages
tend to be more important than another
based on the number of Link's pointing
to that page and then we also talked
about sitemaps so we talked about the
two types of sitemaps HTML and XML HTML
is for the end user
XML is primarily for the search engines
XML generally is going to be a file
called sitemap XML and we could take
that XML file and submit it to Google
search console and so that expedites the
process of indexing your site and helps
your site not only get indexed faster
but will help Google understand how many
pages are on your site and then get
those pages indexed so that they can be
found so that you generate traffic so
all these are factors with on-page SEO
that you want to address before you move
on to off page SEO ok let's turn our
attention to off page SEO now that we
covered all the essentials for on-page
we still need to focus our attention on
off page remember earlier I mentioned
that SEO is a two-pronged approach we
have to focus on on page SEO first and
then to complement our efforts and to
continue our efforts and to continue the
effort of being relevant for certain
keywords we need to do what we call off
page SEO and those are actions we take
that don't involve our website directly
meaning we've already updated the title
tag the Meta Description the alt tags
the headers etc we want to do things off
our website that's going to allow Google
and other search engines to recognize
that hey we are relevant these pages are
relevant for certain keywords on our
website and so really when we talk about
off page SEO it's really the technique
promoting your website using link
building when we say technique of
promoting our website using link
building that means establishing links
on other websites that's what we mean by
link building and so establishing links
on other websites
really
as our SEO efforts because it improves
first and foremost and improves the
credibility of our website so if we're
on a you know a very popular website
that is known to be reputable than
having a link pointing from that website
to ours just improves the credibility of
our own website not necessarily in the
minds of the search engine but in the
minds of the end user the other benefit
here is it increases our domain
Authority and let's take a minute to
talk about domain authority so domain
authority is simply just a score between
1 and 100
and so in digital marketing even
including SEO is a marketing channel
everything is measurable and we want to
be able to measure everything we do
digitally and so off page SEO is
measurable one of the metrics involved
with off page SEO is domain Authority in
other words it's a score between 1 and
100 for our domain so how does Google
how does bi do how do these other search
engines see our domain how authoritative
is our domain how reputable is our
domain
and so having links on other websites
pointing to our domain increases our
reputable bility increases our authority
and so I'm going to show you an example
so if you remember back on on-page SEO I
when we're talking my keyword research
we used a tool called Moz Moz calm and I
would recommend using Moz calm to
measure domain Authority so if we go to
Moz calm and Moz calm has a tool called
link explorer so if you put in your
domain using their tool link explorer
you're gonna be able to see your domain
Authority and domain Authority is a
score between 1 and 100 and basically
it's simply just scoring your website in
terms of authority how does the search
engine see your site out on the World
Wide Web the higher the score the better
and so recommend using Moz comm link
explorer to measure the domain authority
so the more links we have on external
sites pointing
to our own site in theory the higher the
domain authority so we're going to come
back to Moz calm quite frequently as we
talked about off page SEO because we
need a tool to help manage our efforts
so we're going to come back to Moz combo
woods let's talk about some of these
other benefits too off page SEO so we
know it helps with the credibility and
increases our domain Authority but what
are some of the other intangible efforts
that are also measurable well it
increases our referral traffic and by
increasing our referral traffic meaning
if we're on a reputable site that gets a
lot of traffic and there's a link point
in our site then naturally we're
probably going to see traffic coming
from that site and we can measure that
in tools like Google Analytics we can
measure referral traffic and so that's
an inherent benefit to doing off page
SEO because we're trying to create the
relevancy of our own website we're
trying to be found for relevant keywords
but yet at the same time we can increase
traffic to our website and then
certainly not lost in all this is
improving our page rank so the idea here
is you need on-page and off-page SEO to
work together to improve our rankings
and improving our rankings in the search
engine results will inherently increase
our rankings and drive traffic to the
site from search engines and that's
ideally what we're trying to do we're
trying to accomplish traffic from search
engines by improving our rankings but at
the same time we improve our credibility
and we accrue improve our standing in
the search engine world and we also
increase traffic to our site from all
these other websites and so there are a
lot of benefits to off page SEO it's
just let's talk a little bit more about
some of these other benefits because
according to a backlink Oh a web page
with more backlinks is going to rank
higher than a page with fewer backlinks
but let me just say this with back
linking especially from sites it's all
about credibility it's all about quality
over quantity so we want to pay
attention to quality over quantity so
let's harken back to Moz
and here we can see we have a domain
Authority of 35 but we have a lot of
links inbound links from other websites
pointing to our website we have five
hundred and seventy five domains out
there on the internet pointing to our
domain Valley fake com
and so if we want to take a specific
look at these domains we can just simply
click on linking domains and here we can
see all the different domains pointing
to our website now again it's about
quality not quantity
so if we look at the domain Authority
and that's a score that measures the
credibility of a website we could see
the domain Authority on some of these
domains like npr.org has a domain
Authority of 93 and so to me that helps
boost the domain Authority for our own
website our own domain it also has the
chance of driving that traffic it also
increases the credibility but in the end
having quality links from other quality
domains is going to increase our own
rank on search engines and that's the
whole idea behind it so we could
actually see that we have quality
websites of quality domains linking to
our domain now you can also use another
tool I mentioned this earlier with
on-page SEO when I was talking about
sitemaps so if you go to search console
so that's a Google tool we can also look
at a link report and see what other
websites are linking to us so this is
Google's way of communicating to us what
websites are out there linking to us and
so here I can see the top linking sites
to our website valley fig calm is the
crumby kitchen has fourteen hundred and
forty-three links pointing back to our
site cookscountry.com
Whole Foods magazine mind perfect
kitchen these are all sites with links
pointing back to our site so search
console is a good tool it's a good
alternative tool especially the links
report is a good alternative tool to get
an idea
of the types of sites that are linking
to your site now what you're missing
here in search console is the domain
Authority but you can use the link
Explorer tool in moz.com
to measure the domain Authority for any
domain it's just a matter of going to
the tool itself going by going to
moz.com by going to the link explorer
report and just typing in the domain and
from there you'll be able to see the
domain Authority so it's all about
quality over quantity I can't stress
that enough so when it comes to off page
really it's synonymous with link
building so it's the most effective
method for off page SEO and it's simply
just getting links from other websites
to your own so it's not as easy as it
sounds especially when we're talking
about quality over quantity but building
these links to our website will help our
rankings and that's the whole idea
behind off page SEO we want to be able
to link from other websites to ours so
that we can help our rankings in
addition to some of the other benefits I
just mentioned so Google recognizes
backlinks as one of their top ranking
factors so in addition to some of the
on-page SEO tactics that I mentioned
earlier including title tag and Meta
Description and URL structure and
headers all those are important but at
the same time it's a balance so Google
wants to know hey yes we understand
you've optimized your title tag for
keyword but how does the rest of the
internet see your website or is your
website worthy enough to add a link from
a particular quality website to your
website so if there are a number of
quality links then your site must be a
quality as well and so that's the whole
idea behind link building being an
important factor because again it's
about from a Google's perspective it's
about the user experience they want to
make sure that sites ranked on page one
of Google are quality sites quality
sites that load well that have good
content that have fresh content not just
sites that have a gazillion links
pointing to them
with you know keywords stuffed into the
title tag so it's an ecosystem Google's
and other search engines want to protect
that a good system with quality so
that's why link building is an important
factor and so there are different types
of links so when you have a link
pointing from one website to your own ok
the link could be a follow a link or
nofollow link and the whole idea behind
follow or nofollow is simply hey we know
that Google and other search engines
they're spidering the entire web the
whole idea is for them to collect as
many pages as they these search engines
can to bring them back to their servers
so they can serve them up in their
search engines well as Google and these
other search engines spider these sites
they're following what they're doing is
they're following links that's as simple
as it gets they're following links from
one link to another so remember we
talked about internal links earlier on
on-page SEO
internal links are just links on your
web pages pointing to other pages on
your own website well when it comes to
external links so links pointing from
one website to your website that website
that's linking to your website has an
opportunity to say hey Google you can
follow this link or don't follow the
link and so if they choose to not follow
the link meaning they put a nofollow tag
into the anchor text then Google's going
to follow the link but not recognize the
link itself and what I mean by that is
hey if you have let's just use Valley
fig has a link from Wikipedia
if Wikipedia has a link pointing to
Valley fig calm but the link itself is
nofollow then what Google's gonna do is
not recognize the link itself they're
not gonna recognize the link so
therefore you're not going to get credit
or link juice as we say you're not going
to get any juice from Wikipedia - Valley
fig but if it is a follow link then what
Google's going to do is recognize the
link and give you credit for the
backlink and by giving you credit for
the backlink that's going to inherently
increase your domain
it's also going to likely increase your
rankings so you want to pay attention to
the types of link-building that's out
there nofollow and so any time you try
to establish a link on an external
website just make sure it's a follow
make sure it's not a no follow because
if it's a nofollow link then you're not
going to get the credit from the search
engines and so the whole idea behind
link building in terms of SEO is to get
some credit from a quality website to
your website and so if we look here a
follow link in this example is one where
the H ref or the link itself doesn't
have a nofollow in it but if a hyperlink
does have a nofollow in it then that
means you're not gonna get the credit
for the back link so remember no follows
they don't allow search engine crawlers
to follow the link so if that's the case
it's not gonna pass any link juice when
you don't pass quote-unquote link juice
you're not gonna get credit for the back
link and so if you don't get credit for
the back length then if we go back to
our tools that we have available for
measuring off page SEO so if I go back
to let's just say Moz or even let's just
say search console you know I'll be able
to see all these links here these links
that are showing up are follow links why
because Google's recognizing the link if
they were nofollow then we wouldn't see
the link in here so that's something to
keep in mind as well and so just keep in
mind if it is a no fall you'll see in
the hypertext itself the nofollow tag
and you can always check that the HTML
of any particular link and so when we
talk about link building we talked about
off page SEO really we're talking about
how to get links on quality websites and
how do we do that
well I've listed here a few ways to do
that so you could do guest blogging or
blogging in general is a good off page
SEO / link building strategy and I'll
talk about more of that in a minute
but we can list our way
sites in reputable and trustworthy
directories I mentioned Wikipedia as an
example even though Wikipedia may not be
classified as a directory but there are
other directories out there you could
ask for testimonials so if you're
working with clients or other websites
you could ask for testimony or they can
provide it a link pointing back from
their site to your site it's about
relationships really is what it comes
down to its relationship building and
that's what a link is relationship
building or you could do content on
social media so these are just examples
of ways to generate links but let's go
back to the blogging part because
blogging to me is an essential part to
off page SEO and why is that because
anytime you are part of a blog you're
generating content and not only you
generating content you're generating
fresh content that's likely to be
interesting to the end-user and with
that content yes you can optimize that
content but the beauty about blogging is
really anybody can do it but if we want
to connect blogging with relationships
if we're a food blogger then we can
write on other food blogs as a guest
writer and we can have that blog post
link back to our own blog as an example
or we can have other bloggers in the
same industry write a guest blog for us
on their own blog and point their link
back to our site blogging creates a lot
of opportunities for link building
because again it's a fresh canvas with
interesting content and when you have
interesting content then the opportunity
for backlinking is going to be there
because if you're writing about
something that's interesting the natural
are you're going to want to link to
something else related to that that's
interesting and so that's the
opportunity that blogging creates so
again it's vital to get links from
authoritative webpages then multiple
links from low-quality webpages so going
back to the link Explorer report we want
to be able to pay attention to those
domain authorities or those websites
with low domain
and really you should pay attention to
really quality sites okay you want to
pay attention to quality sites and so
when we talked about links there's
inbound links there's outbound links
we're interested in those inbound links
we're interested in getting links from
high quality web sites pointing to our
own website and again that could be in
the form of a blog it could be social
media it could be a partner site okay
these are all inbound links they just
need to be followed make sure they're
not a nofollow so it's simple just
getting a external link that's a follow
to your to your own website and so the
one thing I want to mention here though
on inbound links from external web sites
and that's making sure that not
necessarily every inbound link points to
the home page we want to be able to have
links point to internal pages so let's
park and back to search console as an
example so search console our links
report shows us links pointing from
external websites to our own website but
what are those link pages so if we look
at some of those link pages here we can
see the top link pages we can see I'm
Vali fig comm slash recipes is the
topped link page then the home page then
the about us then slash international so
we want to make sure that if we're
trying to generate backlinks from
external websites to our own website we
want to make sure that they're pointing
to interior pages not necessarily the
home page and why do I say that because
one of the benefits to link building and
off page SEO is ranking so the whole
idea about ranking is to get some of our
other pages rank not necessary the home
page the home page is just a doorway
into your website if we have interesting
content out there on the web and it's a
food blogger as an example and they're
talking about a particular food item
well they're gonna want a link to a page
that's related to what they're blogging
about
the food item they don't want to link to
the home page the home page is just a
doorway and so that's the whole idea
behind link building we want to link to
multiple pages on the site why is that
because if I take this particular page
Valley fig calm slash recipes and I just
put that into Moz and I look at the link
Explorer report for this particular page
the domain Authority is still going to
be the same 35 that's what Valley fig
com is 35 however there's also another
metric called page Authority so page
Authority is likewise with the domain
Authority to score between 1 and 100 and
so the more external links pointing to
an internal page with high domain
Authority that's likely going to
increase the page Authority of that page
so in other words if we have good links
from other websites pointing to that
page then it's going to increase the
page Authority for that page and
ultimately the domain Authority for that
page and so just like the domain
authority in this case Valley fig every
page under the domain has a page
authority score so the higher the score
the likelihood that that page is going
to rank in the search engine results
okay so that's the whole idea behind
link building is we want to improve the
authority of the pages not just the
domain but also more importantly we also
want to keep the end user in mind so if
it's from a blog or social media the
link pointing from that blog or social
media platform should naturally point to
something related to what you're talking
about not just the home page because
again the home page more or less is the
gateway into the website so we want to
get people to where they want to go we
want to naturally create a link from
good content to some other good content
so that's the whole idea behind
backlinking so outbound links will
direct a user from our own website to
another website so the idea here is it's
okay to have outbound links on your own
website the natural ecosystem of the
world wide web okay what I would
recommend ear is
to have so many in a century located
place for example don't have one page
when nothing but external links on it
now sprinkle these external links these
outbound links throughout your website
but also if it's not a reciprocal link
meaning if a guest blogger is not
linking to your website but you're just
linking to theirs and they didn't ask
you to
then maybe consider a nofollow tag maybe
you know ideally you want to make sure
that these links are just natural in
nature so don't just have a habit of
putting outbound links because the whole
idea behind outbound links is you want
to keep people on your website but if
it's a natural link going from one
content to another and you think the end
user is going to benefit then no problem
but just don't get in the habit of
putting external links on your website
because that means that hey that user
that's on your website may click on that
link and leave your website and not come
back so keep that in mind as well
because you don't necessarily benefit
from an SEO perspective by having
outbound links on your own website you
want to do it as a courtesy if somebody
else is linking to you want to do it for
the end user if you feel the benefit
from additional content under the
website but from an SEO perspective it
doesn't necessarily directly enhance
your own website in terms of ranking
sort of our attention to duplicate
content so a lot of us have websites
with a lot of content sometimes we go
ahead and take our website and revise it
create a new one or register a new
domain and put content on that new
domain and so we may find ourselves in a
situation at one point or the other
where we have two websites with the same
content or could be the same website
with a lot of content but some of that
may be duplicate as well so we want to
try and stay away from duplicate content
but for some of us we may stumble across
it accidentally we may find ourselves
having content that's duplicated and so
we want to try and prevent that because
that's a no-no in the world of SEO
so if we have duplicate content
appearing in more than one year
there are ways to rectify not having the
search engines recognize the content
twice so some examples of duplicate
content are for example a spammer takes
an article and post the same content on
his web site or like I mentioned before
you create another website or register
another domain and have that particular
content on the old website stone or
you're writing a blog post and you tag
it or categorize it and the content
shows up under the tags under the
categories and just shows up in general
so there are a lot of scenarios where
you can find your cells with duplicate
content and so we want to rectify that
we don't want duplicate content we want
the search engines to recognize the
original source of the content and so
basically if you have two versions of a
webpage you may result in duplicate
content issues another example that
would be for example if you have
products you may find that that same
product may be under two different
categories so how do we rectify that
well there are a number of different
ways and so the simple way is what they
call a 301 redirect to the original URL
so if you find yourself in a situation
where you have a new website with the
same content you could simply set up a
redirect and we call it a 301 redirect
because 301 refers to permanent so it's
signifying to the search engines that
you're permanently moving from this page
to this page the other way is through a
canonical attribute and so the word
canonical may not register with some of
you so let's just take a minute to talk
about what a canonical is a basically
canonical tag
it's a page level meta tag so remember
that meta tag description we talked
about an on-page SEO well think about
this as another type of meta tag and
it's placed in that HTML header of your
web page so basically all it does is by
placing this meta tag it tells the
search engines which URL is the original
version to be displayed in index so it's
the per
purpose of a canonical is to keep the
duplicate content out of the search
engine index so we want to consolidate
our page rank or page authority or
domain Authority all to original content
that's the whole idea of having a
canonical and it's a quick solution so
all you need to do is add a canonical
tag to the header so let me show you an
example if you have a site let's just
use CNN as an example cnn.com has a lot
of content sometimes giving the umbrella
that they have they may run into
duplicate content so they simply just
put a canonical tag into their their
header and so by doing that they're able
to tell the search engines hey this page
this domain is the original if you find
yourself with multiple sites well you
can also use Google search console so
remember we use Google search console in
earlier examples when we talked about
links to your site or we talked about
that sitemap on page SEO well if we go
in a search console we could basically
say look Google because search console
is a Google tool we want to confirm that
this is our domain so this is the domain
you should be focusing on so you can
leverage search console to communicate
with Google regarding which site is
important which is the one that should
get indexed you can use the canonical
you can put that on any page of your
website or you can set up a 301 redirect
so those are ways to fix duplicate
content issues 301's are the easiest
Canonical's tend to be temporary because
they're just the page level and then
search console is a good method because
it communicates with Google directly and
it allows Google to crawl various web
pages differently than if you didn't
tell them okay so if you didn't tell
them they're just going to grab anything
they can
so by communicating via the Google
search console tool it allows you to
tell Google this is the domain I want to
focus in on so let's talk then now about
how the Google algorithm
work so we'll shift gears here and we'll
talk about how these algorithms work on
Google so Google uses advanced concepts
retrieve data so what they do is they're
spidering their spidering they're
collecting webpages and they're taking
all these webpages back to their server
and anytime somebody does a query
they're delivering those webpages within
milliseconds they're delivering results
based on your query so that's in general
how it works so it uses a combination of
different algorithms to deliver the best
results they want the best results and
so some of the most popular algorithms
below are Google Panda Google penguin
and Google ranked brain so these are all
things that Google has done and to make
sure that they're constantly tweaking
their search engines to deliver the best
results so let's talk about some of
these these popular algorithms and
before we talk about these popular
algorithms so let's just make one thing
clear that Google is always tweaking
their algorithms on their search engine
and so if you want to get an idea how
often they do it well we do it every day
we're constantly tweaking it but then
what they do is they release major
changes to their algorithm a few times a
year so if you want to get a sense of
what those changes look like well you
could go to Moz comm and you can go to
Google - algorithm - change and you can
see here that hey Google changes his
search algorithm around 500 to 600 times
while most of these are minor Google
again rolls out major changes like panda
like penguin that affects search results
in significant ways so you can go here
and you can go all the way back to 2000
and see some of the algorithm changes
that have occurred over the last few
years and you can see here the last
major one was done in August of 2018
that was the medicore update so they're
constantly making changes to their
search engine to deliver a more concise
more better ecosystem for the nu
so if it's a better search engine for
the end user and users are going to come
back so the whole idea is continuing to
tweak the system that the algorithms to
better show more accurate results and so
let's take a look at some of the major
algorithm changes that they have done in
the past so the first is we'll talk
about Google Panda and panda was an
algorithm that was released back in 2011
so here we are in 2019 s a few years ago
but still significant in that really
this algorithm emphasized high quality
content because before panda there was
oh there's just a lot of content out
there on the internet and there was a
lot of spam content there a lot of
duplicate content and so really the idea
behind panda is for Google to really
deliver in their search engine results
pages high quality content so what it
did was it removed web pages that had
low-quality or duplicate content so that
was the whole idea behind you know the
algorithm nicknamed panda it removed
low-quality and duplicate content and
that kind of cleaned things up a bit
where if you did a search query now
you'd actually see better better results
and one thing about panda is because
there's so much quality because Google's
indexing so much there on the internet
that it's constantly being updated it's
updated regularly so the next one we're
going to talk about is Google penguin so
penguin was released after panda and
what that focused in on was low-quality
links so remember we talked about link
building we talked about quality links
over quantity so naturally you're going
to have links naturally from all web
sites whether it be high quality or low
quality the whole idea behind this
algorithm is to sever the links that are
low quality and so the idea behind that
was they focused on two areas so they
focused in on link schemes and keyword
stuffing so that's what penguin focused
on was link schemes were basically
linked almost linked farming where you
produced
mass amounts of backlinks and not all of
them were good quality weren't natural
links links should be natural from one
high quality site or blog to another
high quality site or blog and by
creating links games you've created an
ecosystem where links just went to
irrelevant low-quality spam related
pages and so Google's Penguin's
algorithm update focused in on that
effort to remove or combat pages that
had poor links from being indexed in
their search engine results and then
they also combated keyword stuffing
keyword stuffing is nothing more than
taking your targeted keyword and
stuffing it into the content of your
page or title tag your Meta Description
so any sites that were caught up doing
that basically suffer the consequences
because what penguin did was take care
of sites that basically were accused of
keyword stuffing or had characteristics
of keyword stuffing and they removed
sites that had a lot of links pointing
to it from poor quality sites and
vice-versa sites that really had a lot
of external links pointing to other poor
quality sites so that's what penguin did
they took a look at those two areas I
mean so we talked about link schemes
again Penguins aim was to decrease the
ranking of web pages that created
artificially by using black hat
techniques and basically what I mean by
black hat techniques that artificially
creating length that just didn't make
sense just for the sake of getting the
backlink just for the sake of passing
link juice and so that's what a link
scheme is or was and so Google basically
tweaked their algorithm to combat those
poor link schemes and so keyword
stuffing as I mentioned a minute ago
it's just repetitive usage of the same
keyword and that just basically suffers
the content is the thing that suffers
here and when the content suffers the
end users suffer so Google is all about
quality content and when you have
quality content and that quality
contents indexed and users find what
they're looking for chances are they're
gonna go back to the search engine to
continue to find what they're looking
for with the end result being
with quality content so keyword stuffing
really dilutes the quality of the
content and then let's talk about the
third algorithm which is ranked brain so
rank brain is a processing algorithm
that uses machine learning and what that
does that machine learning interprets
search queries that users search on
google so for example if ranked brain
sees a word or phrase it isn't familiar
with basically the machine can make a
guess as to what words or phrases might
have a similar meaning and filter the
result accordingly so basically take
these search engine queries and present
them in a way that's logical so that the
end result can be something that's
relevant to what you're looking for and
so for example if you're searching for
online marketing you will get results
related for digital marketing on search
engine result pages
why because rank brain will interpret
that particular keyword and they're
trying to basically match based on all
the data they collected what words or
phrases might have a similar meaning so
online marketing digital marketing have
similar meanings now that we've talked
about some of the different algorithm
changes that Google has made over the
years and continues to make let's Segway
into the types of SEO and so when we
talk about the types of SEO we're really
talking about doing what's right what's
expected versus doing something that you
know is trying to cheat the system and
so you may hear the terminology black
cat I see a white hat SEO or grey hat
SEO and so the whole idea behind these
terminologies is that hey what are we
supposed to be doing here in terms of
following best practices in order to get
our pages ranked on the search engines
for the keyword queries week of it and
so let's talk about what not to do first
and that's always black hat techniques
so I just mentioned a minute ago with
panda and penguin algorithm updates you
know penguin took into account you know
link schemes poor linking techniques
keyword stuffing so those are considered
black hat techniques so black hat
is a technique used to improve page rank
by violating search engine rules and
policies so it's clearly Google's made a
clear line in the sand they don't like
links gains they don't like keyword
stuffing so if you take into account
those practices then your practicing
black hat techniques to treat this cheat
the system to try and rank faster and so
some other ways of blackhat or you know
redirecting fishing having duplicate
content all these are are things that
are frowned upon by search engines so
the result of not only algorithm changes
is you could get your website
blacklisted from the search engines if
you are caught in violation of their
policies it's pretty clear-cut so that's
why the algorithms are in place the
algorithms try and create a system and
environment where you know good quality
content is shown so if your keyword
stuffing or creating lots of duplicate
content that's not in adherence with you
know Google's policies for creating good
quality content and as a result you
could get blacklisted
so with black hat techniques you run the
risk of being penalized and you don't
want to be penalized by the search
engines so white hat contrarily used to
improve search engine rankings by
following those rules and policies so in
effect it's everything we talked about
today from on-page SEO to off page SEO
doing the right thing with your content
in terms of organizing the structure
with headers creating very clear and
concise meta descriptions submitting a
sitemap all of those are white hat
techniques addressing page load time
using really relevant keywords naturally
in your content and creating high
quality content that's fresh and
interesting for the end user that's
white hat technique that's going to get
you ranked higher and farther and with
better benefits so gray hat is just
simply a combination of black and white
it's when practice of improving by
following the policies but they
considered you know ethically dubious
and so what I mean by that is
listen.you you don't want to purchase
links you want links to come across
naturally you don't want to do excessive
internal linking you don't want to have
a lot of Link's pointing to one page
it's not natural so you want to be able
to do things that are natural you don't
want to just take content from another
side and claim it as your own so you
want to do things that are natural
that's going to create a good experience
for the user because if it's for the end
user which it is then generally it's
going to be good for the search engines
and so let's talk about website
architecture now
so basically when I say website
architecture what I mean is we want to
give the search engines an idea of how
our websites built so website
architecture and the structure of Roman
sites important and so every website has
a hierarchy it starts with the home page
the home page is the top page it's the
the domain it's where most people go to
find other pages of your website and so
generally you're gonna have a scenario
where you're gonna have a home page with
you know if you sell products multiple
categories and in those categories you
can have multiple products so the
generally that's how a web architecture
flows it's closed from top down and the
reason for having a good website
architecture is internal links are
spread equally so you want to make sure
again not to apply a black hat method or
a grey hat method of pointing all links
to one page you want links naturally to
spread throughout your website because
not just from an SEO benefit but from an
end-user perspective you want users to
flow through your website naturally so
if you're de planning on developing
websites from an SEO perspective you
know take these things in consideration
so we want to take into account the site
architecture and navigation we want to
take into account the URL remember we
talked about your a rel structure and
on-page SEO the rule of thumb is if you
can read it the search engines will read
it so we want to keep it clear and
concise and relevant to the content of
the
when we talk about responsive design
we're talking about multiple devices so
you don't build a website just for
desktop especially when mobile is being
used by a majority of the users around
the world so you want to build a website
that's both desktop friendly and mobile
friendly we also want to take into
account a robots.txt file and a
robots.txt file simply just a text file
that allows the search engines to index
certain pages it tells them what not to
index and so you can always find the
robots.txt file normally if you go to a
website and let's just say we go to
Valley fig com and then we type in robot
or robots.txt file here we could see if
I type in robots.txt file here this
basically is a file a text file that's
in the root directory and it simply just
gives the search engines an idea of what
they're allowed to index and what
they're not allowed to index so anything
with a disallow means hey search engines
please don't index these pages so that's
what a robots.txt file does and every
site should have it because there are
some pages on your website then you
inherently don't want the search engines
to index and you want to optimize for
the crawlers so that means that making
sure that your pages are available and
that means also submitting a sitemap
remember we submit our sitemap via the
Google search console so good site
architecture not only makes content easy
to find but also helps to gain traffic
because hey if your site is easy its
well-organized it's built multiple
devices the URLs are easy then all
that's going to be apparent to the
search engines and when it's apparent to
the search engines it's going to get
indexed I'm going to get indexed then
you're going to get found and you're
gonna get the traffic so it's just a
natural progression it's best practice
so some important features of good
architecture are again that you're all
structure code your site navigation and
CSS or HTML make it easy for the search
engines to follow build a comprehensive
structure for an internal linking
meaning they should be matched
internal links if a page is relevant to
another page then create an internal
link if you have a very big website with
a lot of content or a lot of products
then create a breadcrumb navigation
okay so we're may be familiar with that
on Amazon as an example amazon.com has a
lot of products and if you're navigating
from one product to another in one
directory or one category to another
category that Amazon creates what they
call breadcrumbs to help you navigate
back to where you were quickly so these
are all good best practices for good
site architecture good site architecture
equals search engine results so
responsive design house to make your
website mobile-friendly it will increase
the amount of time the user spends on
your website which may improve site
rankings so let's talk a second about
mobile friendliness so if i go back to
google search console there happens to
be in search console a mobile usability
report and so if I click on that report
basically what it's going to show me is
pages that are do not follow Google's
best practices so some of Google's best
practices are making sure that the text
is easy to read that clickable elements
aren't necessarily close to one another
and the viewport is set to the
appropriate device meaning the screen is
set to the appropriate device okay and
so basically if we are found in
violation then the page is affected are
going to get flagged by Google and if
the page is affected or flagged by
Google then those pages won't get
indexed and so we want to keep an eye on
the mobile usability report and Google
search console so remember it's better
to have a good site architecture that
BOTS can easily index so BOTS will give
preference to web pages with relevant
content and in the end it will help your
website rank better and as a side note
always use a sitemap to
easy for the pots to crawl your website
so we covered that an on page as a
reminder if I go back to search console
and if I click on sitemaps I can go
ahead and submit my site map so if I
created an XML version of my site map
called Simon XML and I submit that
basically what I'm doing is I'm saying
hey Google here's my sitemap file and in
that sitemap file or all the pages on my
website that want to get indexed and
when you submit your sitemap to Google
basically they're going to discover
those URLs and index those URLs and
their search index and that expedites
the process of getting indexed it
expedites the process of getting found
on search and it expedites the process
of getting clicks on your search results
pages and and having that traffic go to
your website where they can enjoy the
user experience and convert and remember
the robots.txt file is there to allow
google and other search engines to know
what pages to crawl so good website
architecture like for example Amazon
they use breadcrumbs they have a
hierarchy in terms of categories okay so
you can see how its evenly dispersed on
the left side on the right side a poor
website architecture is very slanted in
one direction a lot of internal links no
breadcrumbs the navigation isn't very
clear so we want to make sure things are
simple and easy so let's turn our
attention to local SEO so local SEO is
for those businesses who focus on a
specific market it could be a whole
state like the state of Florida and the
United States it could be a specific
city in a particular state like Orlando
Florida or Miami it really depends on
the business and who you are trying to
attract and what geolocation you are
trying to attract so if you're trying to
attract a segment of audience in a
specific location then local SEO should
be
in your sites for optimization and so we
talked about local SEO we're really
talking about optimizing your website to
get traffic from a specific location so
that's what local SEO it and the idea
behind local SEO is to put your
particular service or product or
whatever it is you're offering to that
particular geo market that particular
locale or that city or that state so you
want to put yourself in front of the
right audience that's the whole idea
behind local SEO and so if we focus in
on Google you know local results are
based on three factors and this is
according to Google so it's based on a
relevancy so if somebody's looking for a
plumber and you happen to be a plumber
in that particular locale or city or zip
code then chances of you getting found
are gonna be great because of relevancy
and then distance so where that person
is located based on your address or
where you're located has a role in how
you display on local SEO and then
prominence
so prominence is also very important
because you know how prominent are you
as a business are you getting a lot of
reviews do you have a lot of different
locations do you have all your photos
and all your information posted to
prominence does play a bit of factor
along with distance along with the
relevancy on Google local SEO so these
factors combined to help find the best
match for your search there's somebody
typing in that plumber or say that
Italian restaurant or any particular
product or service is going to find
local results and you want to be there
to to meet that person when they're
looking for your product or service
so that's the whole idea behind local
SEO and so one of the factors with local
SEO is having consistent and AP or not
and so what is an IP it's really name
address and phone number so it sounds
very simple and it is simple you just
have to be consistent so if you have a
local SEO presence on say Bing sir
Jinjin you want to make sure that the
name address and phone number are can
also the same name and address and phone
number on google so it's just about
consistency so that's what we want to do
we want to make sure that we're
consistent across the board because it's
important for companies that want to
wait well have some consistency and it's
important to when we talk about
consistency to actually have that
information you need obviously the name
of your company you obviously need a
phone number and you need to put your
address in there but really of all three
the phone numbers just as important
because we talked about local SEO we
mentioned mobile earlier we know that a
lot of people initiate their search on
mobile and so if they're looking for
local restaurant or local cafe or that
plumber and you appear in local SEO then
your phone number is going to appear
with the results and that gives an
opportunity for some money to go ahead
and just click on that number to call it
just makes it that much easier for
somebody to get in touch with you so
consistency and having all your
information are important factors for
local SEO so having an inconsistent nap
if you will is not going to bode well
for you on the local SEO results okay
it's important because it offers up
legitimate legitimacy it offers up
better rankings and at the end of the
day it's going to help you get those
calls it's going to help you get traffic
to your website so for example if a
particular company that sells Coomer
running shoes has a yellowpages.com
listing we want to be consistent if it's
on yellowpages.com and this is their
address on their website then you need
to be consistent with that if it's
inconsistent and we're talking about
very minor details but these minor
details are important simply just
putting Rd as road and then spelling out
row is gonna cause some inconsistency so
consistency is very important why
because local SEO is also tied to
mapping you know Google Maps and so
Google wants to see consistency so that
they can offer up the address and the
mapping services so that's one good
reason why it needs to be consistent
another
is again you know so many may want to
drive to your location or call your
location or see if that location is
close to them so that's why consistency
is such a key component to local SEO so
in order to get started on Google for
local SEO what you want to do is you
want to just do a search for Google my
business so Google my business is the
platform in which you're going to set up
your local business and once you set up
your Google my business account whatever
that account is you want to make sure
you have all the credible information in
there I can't stress that enough you
need to have that phone number you need
to have that address and needs to be
consistent but with Google my business
there's a lot of things you can do here
so you can manage reviews so if you do
have a location you can go ahead and
manage those reviews that somebody puts
in for your business and so if it's a
negative review you definitely want to
respond to that negative review if it's
a positive review you definitely want to
respond to that positive review so you
can manage reviews you can upload photos
so photos is a big component as we
talked about with alt tags and images
you know having these images helped up
here in the local SEO results you can
manage a lot of other things your
information you can manage post you can
offer up promotions there's a lot of
things you could do you could set your
business hours so the more information
you put in to Google my business the
more informations gonna can be conveyed
to the end-user looking for your
products and services and Google my
business even goes as far as offering up
the opportunity to have a website so if
you're a business that doesn't even have
your own website you can create a
website right in Google my business and
so the end result is this if somebody is
looking for let's just say lice removal
and Orlando let's just say your child
comes home from school with some lice
you need services that offer up lice
removal well you're gonna be able to see
businesses listed in the Orlando region
and then offer up the service you're
looking for and if you're on a mobile
phone you can go ahead and quickly you
know call that person you can go to the
website you look at the reviews so
local seo is a very important to local
businesses very important and so you
want to make sure you have consistent
presence not just on google but i'm
being in some of these other local
platforms like yellowpages.com for
example
so being prominent across multiple
platforms is going to put yourself in
front of the right audience who's
looking for your products and services
let's talk about how to measure your SEO
performance so all that hard work you've
done with on-page SEO and coupled with
all the work you've done with off page
SEO are eventually going to net results
and positive results and we want to be
able to measure that as you're actually
doing the work as you're putting forth
the effort on on-page and off-page and
so we want to be able to measure that
and so you want to be able to understand
what to measure and where to measure it
and so when we talk about SEO we really
want to hone in on three high-level core
metrics and that's ranking trafficking
inversion so when we talk about ranking
traffic and conversion we can break that
down into this list here what kind of
traffic are we getting from organic
search what kind of traffic are we
getting from mobile devices remember
mobile is very important because as we
talked about with on-page SEO as we
talked about with local SEO a lot of
searches start with mobile devices we
want to look at keyword ranking remember
keyword research is the first step in
the SEO process even before we do any
work with on-page and off-page you know
we want to look at the local visibility
if we have local SEO results we want to
look at engagement metrics so all that
traffic we're driving from organic
search we want to be able to measure how
they're performing and behaving on our
website we also want to measure some
form of progress on off page SEO and
that's in the form of backlinks so all
of these are different metrics we can
measure using different tools so let's
talk about how to go about looking at
these metrics
somewhere to go look at them and measure
them and so really monitoring all this
behavior will help us understand how
we're performing how SEO is performing
and so really what we want to do is
start with organic traffic and so we can
look at that on a month-to-month basis
we can look at it from a geographic
perspective we can look at it in terms
of how many new visitors were driving
versus returning and then again more
importantly conversion rate and so to me
the best place to start to look at that
traffic from organic search is Google
Analytics and Google Analytics is a free
tool it's simply there to measure
website performance so if you go into
Google Analytics we can actually go in
and we can look at all sorts of data
based on website behavior and so if I'm
in Google Analytics and I go under
acquisition and then I go under all
traffic channels over a given period of
time let's just say the last seven days
for particular website I can see what
traffic is coming from organic search
and then I could see the amount of new
users that are coming from organic
search I can also see engagement metrics
bounce rate for example so I want to be
able to see if somebody's typing in a
query clicking on our link in the
organic search results and then coming
to our website are they actually
engaging with their website or are they
leaving the website after only visiting
the page they landed on so that's all in
these are all important metrics to
measure and I can measure all that right
here in Google Analytics if I wanted to
I can even take it a step further and
break that down by country so if I type
in country as a secondary dimension now
I could see what country is driving
traffic from organic search so a lot of
your organic traffic information it's
gonna be centrally located in Google
Analytics so we also talked about mobile
traffic a majority of searches take
place on mobile phones versus desktop so
Google basically is reporting that
nearly 60% of searches now appear from
mobile
and so if we go back to google analytics
we can also look at a mobile report so
if I go in Google Analytics under
audience under mobile overview I can see
a breakdown of the amount of traffic
coming from desktop versus tablet versus
mobile and so you'll find as time goes
on that your mobile device is likely
going to drive a majority of the traffic
from organic search and so you can
compare device information with channel
so if I just type in channel in Google
Analytics as a secondary dimension and
look at the default channel groupings
versus device category I can see that
you know mobile from organic search just
driven traffic over the last seven days
this is something you want to keep an
eye on because a lot of people tend to
begin their searches on mobile devices
so mobile ranking is different than
desktop ranking because with mobile
ranking it's based on a responsive
website and with that responsive website
basically responsive being that the
website's going to adapt to the mobile
device so it's gonna respond to the
device that somebody's on and so
therefore the metrics or the engagement
metrics are going to be different but if
I look back to Google Analytics I can
see again bounce rate I can see pages
per session average session duration so
if I look at line three I could see all
the different engagement metrics
compared to those metrics from other
devices and other channels okay so you
want to be able to do a comparison
because if behavior is not up to par
engagement is not the power on mobile
then you want to do something about that
so you want to hone in on mobile traffic
specifically from organic search because
the behavior is gonna be different you
know people start their searches on
mobile the site's gonna be different and
so therefore it's a different experience
altogether so make sure you track the
behavior and more importantly make sure
you track that page speed so earlier we
talked about on-page SEO when we honed
pagespeed so just as a reminder if I'm
back in analytics and I go back under
behavior then if I go to site speed then
if I go to overview I'll be able to see
the average page load time on my website
I can also look at specific page timings
and I should be able to see that by
device so if I type in device category
I'm gonna be able to see how each paid
loads per device and so this allow me to
understand which pages are loading fast
which pages are not loading as fast and
address those pages accordingly to
improve engagement metrics so we want to
keep an eye on page speed as well as
overall user behavior from a lot of Isis
you can also use other tools that are
out there like agency analytics there
are plenty of tools out there I tend to
use Google Analytics because primarily
it's free and Google Analytics is a
Google product so it works with other
Google platforms like Google search
console we want to keep an eye on
ranking so remember when we do our
keyword research we're choosing keywords
that have high relevancy high volume and
low competition so we want to be able to
track keywords that we choose that have
high relevancy high volume and low
competition and so the tool we use or at
least I recommend using is ma so I
mentioned Moz earlier with on-page and
off-page SEO so if we go into Moz and we
know what keywords we're trying to rank
for we can go ahead and add the namaz
and what Moz does they actually track
where these keywords rank and so if I go
into Moz and I click on rankings I'll be
able to see on a weekly basis or a
monthly basis how our keywords are
ranking and for what pages they're
ranking so for whatever keyword I choose
to to optimize for I want to make sure I
put those keywords in Moz because when I
put them in Moz Moz is going to on a
weekly basis tell me where these
keywords rank and for what URL they're
ranked for so that way I can keep an eye
on ranking over time because in theory
the higher you rank but more traffic
you're gonna get and so we want to be
able
to see the trend in which keywords rank
okay so if I click on a particular
keyword in Moz
it's gonna give me over a period of time
where that keywords ranks be able to see
improvement in ranking for particular
keyword the whole idea behind SEO is to
choose keywords that are relevant
optimized for those keywords so that you
can be ranked for those keywords in
order to get the traffic and conversions
so Moz is a good platform that helps us
monitor rankings for particular keywords
now if you don't want to use Moz as an
alternative you can turn your attention
to Google search console and so remember
we talked about Google search console
earlier when we talked about sitemaps we
also talked about mobile usability with
search console we also talked about
links to your site with Google search
console so Google search console is a
good tool to help you understand how
you're performing with organic search
and so there's one tool in particular
which is performance that helps us
understand what keyword queries people
are actually typing into Google search
and so here I could see the actual query
and so with this particular website
valley fig com I can see that dried fig
recipes over the course of the last
three months have 5414 impressions that
means that one of my pages either one or
multiple pages appeared in Google search
engine results 5414 times and over the
course of this 5414 impressions I
received 1100 clicks so Google search
console is gonna be able to tell me not
only you know how many impressions I
received for a particular keyword but
they also going to tell me how many
clicks and if I wanted to add more
metrics to that I can add them like the
average ranking position for a keyword
the click-through rate so I can add
multiple metrics to this report to give
me an understanding of hey or any of my
targeted keywords being used or queried
and if they are where my ranking and I
am i showing up and am i getting clicks
so search console serves is a good
alternative if not primary
tool or platform for you to measure how
your organic search results are showing
so for local visibility this metric is
important for you know maintaining local
SEO so remember on the local SEO we
talked about Google my business so if I
go back to Google my business I can go
into my account and so Google my
business is going to be able to show me
some metrics so if I go into Google my
business and I click on insights I'm
gonna be able to see a number of
different metrics over the course of a
month I can see exactly you know what
queries were used by how many users and
when I appeared so I'll be able to see
how many views I receive not only on
search results but on maps then I can
also see what actions people took when
they saw my results in maps or in search
did they visit my website through their
request directions did they call so I
can actually see engagement metrics
right in Google my business I could see
a break out by zip code I can see phone
calls by day of the week I could see how
many people even viewed my photos so
there's a lot of insights into local SEO
on Google my business so that gives you
an idea of how you're performing
organically on local search and remember
you want to be able to use Google my
business to hone in on your specific
audience so all these metrics help you
aligned with whether you're getting in
front of the right audience and what are
that audience is actually behaving the
way you want them to meaning you know
are they actually contacting you are
they going to your website are they
calling you so local visibility and
understanding the metrics involve the
local SEO is very important so Google my
business is where you want to turn your
attention so overall engagement metrics
are important they play an important
role in determining rankings for example
we talked about bounce rates a bounce
rate is the rate at which people go from
organic search to your website and then
leave after a seen one page and not
going any further so if they land on a
page and then leave the website
landing on that page it's considered a
bounce and so bounce or bounce rate is a
good indication of how people are
receiving our website or the content
that they're reading on our website
there are other metrics involved like
average session duration or pages per
visit
all of these are engagement metrics and
let's not forget about page speed so
page speed is also a good engagement
metric all of these metrics affect or
determine rankings so we want to be able
to make sure that if we're in Google
Analytics and we're looking at
engagement metrics that our metrics are
good because if somebody comes to our
website from organic search and there's
a high bounce rate then what does that
tell us that there's a disconnect
between what that person's Quarian and
then the content that they're reading
and so we want to be able to address
those engagement metrics so that we can
continue to not only drive quality
traffic but keep the traffic engaged and
then in turn drive up conversions last
metric we want to look at is backlinks
so content having more backlinks from
good domains will effectively improve
your SEO performance we talked about
backlinks with off page SEO and remember
quality over quantity and so we can
measure backlinks going back into Moz we
can use Mazdas link explorer tool so
remember if I type in a domain valley
fig I can get some metrics related off
page SEO including my domain Authority
but more importantly I can see what
links are pointing to my site in this
case valley fig com so I can see there
575 link domains I can see there are
seven thousand nine hundred inbound
links and so just by clicking on that I
can get a idea of the types of websites
that are linking to my site and their
domain Authority
in there spam score Google search
console so if you go back into search
console you can also just click on links
and we should be able to get an idea of
you know what websites are linking to
our site and more importantly we want to
be able to see not only what sites for
what pages they're linked to remember we
want our backlinks pointing to interior
pages not necessarily the home page so
here I can see the top linked page for
valley fig comm is slash recipes so we
want links pointing to our interior page
is not necessary the home page that's
what's going to help your performance
your rankings for all your pages not
just your home page so having quality
back links pointing to interior pages
help boost the domain Authority and the
page authority for that particular page
so again using Moz slink Explorer tool
or using the links report in search
console are good sources for you to
identify backlinks so when we look at
these these reports we want to look at
the domain authority of these sites that
are linking ours the number of outbound
links to the site or specific pages on
our site we want to be able to look at
the ratio of link distribution you know
we want to be able to look at how many
follows and nofollow so most of this if
not all of these metrics are in Moz so
if I go back to Moz I can actually see
you know which ones pointing which ones
are followed the total quality of the
link that's pointing to our site again
BAM
so Moz link Explorer report tends us
give us all the information we need in
order to measure and get a sense of our
backlinks that help us with off page SEO
so there are other tools out there
there's a traffic answer console there's
other SEO platforms out there that'll
help you measure backlinks okay now that
we covered everything
with on-page SEO and off page SEO and
really everything SEO in general let's
take a little quiz and if you could go
ahead and just put your answers in the
comment section below
so just a little quiz here and we'll
start out with question 1 which of the
following type of site map is
specifically designed for search spiders
so the answer is either a HTML sitemap
or B XML sitemap so go ahead and put
your answers in the comment section
below I'll give you just another second
to think about that okay another
question for you from a search engine
perspective which of the following link
types could cause a negative effect on
your rankings
it's either a purchase link or B
nofollow link so again if you could if
you know the answer or just take an
educated guess go ahead and put the
answers in the comment section below
next question a website's robots.txt
file serves what function is it a tell
the bots what pages should be crawled
and not crawled or B tell us the bots
what links should be follow and no
follow so if you know the answer you
feel good about your answer go ahead and
put it in the comment section below
ok let's do a recap on some of the key
takeaways from today's a session about
SEO so we started out with why SEO and
why do we want to take part and put some
time and effort into search engine
optimization if you recall one of the
biggest factors was it increases
visibility on search engines so if
you're not getting any traffic to your
website if you don't have any other
marketing channels that you're currently
working on such as social or blogging or
paid search then SEO will definitely
help increase your visibility then we
moved over to what is SEO so we talked a
lot about you know not only the benefits
of SEO but what's involved with
practicing search engine optimization
and we know it's the practice of getting
traffic
organic search from really any search
engine we honed in today on Google but
really when it comes to SEO it's every
search engine so we want to be able to
be relevant for certain keyword queries
on the search engines we focused our
attention on two keyword research so we
talked about what's involved with
keyword research we talked about short
tail keywords remember short tail
keywords or three key words or less
longer tail keywords or three key words
or more and really when it comes to
short tail keywords they're generally
broad in nature they have high search
volume but they're very competitive
because they're broad in nature and the
conversion rates tend to be a little bit
lower because of the relevancy factor
however if you focus it on longer tail
keywords if you recall generally they're
longer in nature low volume however if
somebody's types in a longer tail
keyword and you rank for that long tail
keyword chances are it's gonna be a
little bit more relevant for the end
users so when they actually click on
your link and the search engine results
and go to your website your conversion
rate increases so it's a balance between
short tail and long tail
we then transition to how search engines
work more search engines send out BOTS
to your website they want to crawl your
website and by crawling what they do is
they follow links ok they follow
internal links and external links so in
fact when they're following links
they're creating a sort of a web if you
will so that's where we get the term
spidering from there they're spinning a
web on all these links that they're
following and what they do is when they
follow they're really collecting and
they're collecting all that content and
bringing it back to their servers
because when they bring the content back
to their servers when somebody actually
does a search on the search engine then
the search engine itself is able to you
know spin results in milliseconds based
on the relevancy of that quick keyword
query so that's in general how search
engines work now they have an idea of
how search engines work and why you
should do as the
and the importance of measuring longtail
versus short tail keywords we went into
the actual practical application and if
you remember it's a two-pronged approach
on page SEO and off page SEO so for
on-page SEO it's everything that
involves your website so we talked about
making changes or optimizing your
website to be relevant for certain
keywords we went through a number of
different factors we talked about schema
and title tags and header tags if you
remember header tags had a hierarchy h1
h6 we talked about what a featured
snippet is you know whether it was a
list or a paragraph we talked about the
importance of page speed remember you
can look at page speed in Google
Analytics you want to be able to make
sure your page is load between three to
four seconds max because the longer
takes a page the load the higher that
bounce rates gonna be and the lower that
conversion rates going to be we talked
about the importance of internal linking
and how you can measure internal linking
in search console and speaking of search
console we also made mention that you
can upload a sitemap so the HTML sitemap
is for the end-user the XML sitemap is
for the search engines we can go ahead
and take that XML sitemap it's submit it
to the search engines so that they can
recognize all the pages on your website
so these are some of the key factors of
aam page and when you do on-page then
you transition over to off page SEO and
off page SEO is really synonymous with
link building and why do we do link
building well we talked about some of
the benefits it definitely improves the
credibility of your website because if
you have a link pointing from another
credible website to yours then naturally
the credibility is going to be there not
only for the end user but for the search
engine and as a result of being linked
from quality websites or credible
websites it's going to increase a metric
called domain Authority remember domain
Authority is a score between 1 and 100
and the higher domain Authority the more
relevant you're going to be in the eyes
of the search engines in order to be
relevant you need backlinks or external
links from quality websites
and because you have links from quality
websites the likelihood of you getting
more traffic is going to increase so one
of the net benefits of getting backlinks
is you're going to get traffic from
those websites especially if they're
credible and they're popular and they
get a lot of traffic themselves and so
all of this leads to off page SEO which
is in turn what we want to do is improve
our page rank so we want to prove our
rankings in the search engine results
pages and when we improve our rankings
in the search engine results pages in
effect we're going to get more traffic
from search engines so off page SEO is
very critical that with on-page SEO
balances out the relevancy factor and
you want to be relevant in the eyes of
the search engines for your targeted
keywords we then shifted gears and we
talked about some other factors along
the lines of search engine optimization
including duplicate content so search
engines don't like duplicate content see
if we recall we talked about ways to
combat duplicate content we talked about
setting up redirects we also talked
about canonical tags remember canonical
tags or tags we put in as a meta tag and
that's going to alert the search engines
hey this particular domain this
particular page is the initial source
pay attention to this page we talked
about Google's algorithms and Google
makes tweaks to their search engines
every day and because they make tweaks
to their search engines every day
they're trying to fine-tune it and
usually you're gonna find that Google in
particular is going to have one or two
major algorithm changes once a year and
so we talked about some of the key
algorithm changes as Google's made over
the last couple of years including panda
which took into account quality of
content or Google penguin which took
into account links Keamy
okay so we want to stay away from link
farming and you want to be able to
create good quality content so that's
what these particular algorithms took
into account and then of course Google
ranked brain which basically is
synonymous
learning so Google's search engines are
continuously learning what people type
in as queries and because they're
learning what people type in they're
starting to form their search engine
results based on what they've previously
learned so that's what rankbrain is it's
on artificial intelligence or machine
learning and Google initiated rankbrain
back in 2015 so Google is constantly
making changes to their search engines
for the better
they want a more solid more relevant set
of results to improve the entire
ecosystem of search and some of the SEO
techniques that we talked about in order
to be relevant for certain keyword
queries and we talked about the
techniques that you should apply and
those techniques are white hat
techniques so you want to be able to
follow certain best practices you want
to stay away from black hat SEO or grey
hat SEO black hat SEO you know are
things that you would do to kind of
circumvent best practices like link
farming so you want to take into account
everything we talked about in today's
tutorial because it follows the best
practices not only Google but all search
engines we talked about website
architecture and how important that is
for SEO
I think the key takeaways here is
responsive design remember Mobile is
very important in terms of organic
search and the eyes of Google most users
conduct or initiate their search on a
mobile device and so therefore it's
imperative that you as a website owner
have a responsive design for your
website meaning that design caters to
the device that somebody's going to your
website with so if it's a mobile device
the website should respond to the mobile
device meaning take into account best
practices we talked about having
consistent URL structure having
robots.txt files or robots.txt file is a
file that allows the search engines to
understand what pages to index and what
pages not to embed we shifted gears and
talked about local SEO local SEO is for
those businesses that are targeting a
specific market
that'd be a town a locale a municipality
a city or state local SEO is a strategy
and remember the benefit of local SEO is
you appear above the organic search
results so if your local business
catering to say people looking for
plumbers then you have the opportunity
to be listed above organic search
results and one thing you need to do
that we talked about was just be
consistent with now name address and
phone number and so if you're consistent
with nap and you take advantage of
everything that Google my business has
to offer then your chances of being
found locally are going to be good and
we capped everything off with
measurement so how to measure your SEO
performance this was last but certainly
not least so we talked about specific
metrics in terms of organic traffic
mobile traffic backlinks local
visibility keyword ranking so some of
the tools I mentioned in today's
tutorial was Google Analytics so Google
Analytics is a free tool and it will
help you measure the traffic you're
getting from your website from mobile
from organic search and you compare that
traffic against specific engagement
metrics like bounce rate like time on
pay or conversion or conversion rate
okay so Google Analytics helps you
understand how your visitors are
behaving on your website from mobile
organic search we talked about Google my
business again because with Google my
business
they provide insights into how people
are searching what search keyword
queries they're using and if you're
being found for those search engine
queries and if you are found what are
people what actions are people taking
are they actually calling you are they
looking for directions are they going to
your website so Google my business has
insights that provide information into
your local visibility for SEO we also
mentioned Moz Moz was a tool we
mentioned throughout the tutorial we
used it in our keyword research we used
it in terms of talking about keyword
ranking we also used it in terms of off
page SEO remember the link Explorer
our tool will allow us to measure what
our domain and page Authority is and the
quality of backlinks that we have okay
so Maas fills the role with keyword
ranking and backlink so we can get
really good information in terms of you
know what backlinks are hitting our site
and the quality of those backlinks but
also keyword ranking remember when we
target certain keywords we want to be
able to allow Moz to track the rankings
of these keywords because in theory the
higher a keyword ranks the more traffic
you're going to get from the search
engine so Moz Google my business Google
Analytics for three of the main tools we
talked about there are plenty of other
tools like SEM Rush H refs there's a lot
of different tools out there that we
mentioned that are available to you so
go ahead and use the tools that you feel
comfortable with these are the tools
that I only mentioned that I'm
comfortable with with SEO so the key
here is though you need to measure
performance that's the key takeaway so
thank you for listening to today's
tutorial if you have any more
information or any questions about SEO
visit simply learn com for more
information thank you hi there if you
like this video subscribe to the simply
learn youtube channel and click here to
watch similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here